en directo América llegó el momento de
hablar de economía por ello le doy la
bienvenida a mi compañero Jorge Hurtado
Jorge qué tal Muy bien Andrés Jorge
cuéntenos Qué ha pasado con las
negociaciones sobre el techo de la deuda
en Estados Unidos Bueno este acuerdo
básicamente va a especificar la cantidad
Total que el gobierno podría gastar en
programas discrecionales como vivienda y
educación aunque no desglosaría en
categorías individuales según una fuente
cercana a la casa blanca la falta de
acuerdos que ya se ha tomado bastantes
meses mantiene nervioso los
inversionistas afectando las acciones
estadounidenses y también encareciendo
el costo del endeudamiento de ese país
el presidente Joe biden afirmó que
evitará el impago mientras avanza la
carrera por encontrar un acuerdo entre
la casa blanca y los negociadores
republicanes sobre este importante
asunto escuchamos que decía hoy macarthy
y yo hemos tenido varias conversaciones
productivas y de hecho nuestro personal
continúa reuniéndose mientras hablamos y
están progresando dejé en claro una y
otra vez que el incumplimiento de pago
de nuestra deuda nacional no una opción
el pueblo estadounidense merece saber
que los pagos del seguro social estarán
allí que el hospital de veteranos
permanecerá abierto y que se logrará un
progreso económico y lo Seguiremos
logrando el default pone todo eso en
riesgo los líderes del Congreso
entienden eso y todos han acordado que
no habrá incumplimiento es hora de que
el congreso actúe ahora bien vamos a
seguir ahí en Estados Unidos Jorge
porque se revelaron los datos de
crecimiento del primer trimestre bueno
la mayor Economía del mundo creció
apenas 1,3% entre enero y marzo de este
año eso respecto al año anterior el
crecimiento se ve afectado por el sector
empresarial que temeroso de una
desaceleración económica recortaron sus
inventarios el dato brindado por el
Departamento de comercio sobre el
crecimiento del producto interno bruto
de ese país muestra que la producción
total de bienes y servicio se desaceleró
respecto al crecimiento anual del 3,2%
de Julio a septiembre Y del 2,6 que se
reportó entre octubre y diciembre pese a
esto el gasto de los consumidores que
representa alrededor del 70% de la
producción económica de Estados Unidos
aumentó un 3,8% anual es el mayor en
casi dos años y según los expertos es
una muestra de la confianza que tienen
los hogares en esa economía vamos a
dejar Estados Unidos y vamos a ir ahora
a Chile donde el Banco Central ordenó a
la banca una subida del capital como
medida anti crisis bueno Es la primera
vez que se toma en Chile una medida como
es tomó por sorpresa por supuesto a los
banqueros los bancos chilenos deberán
aumentar su capital en un 0,5% de los
activos ponderados por riesgo en un
plazo de 12 meses El Banco Central
argumentó la decisión tras la quiebra de
bancos estadounidenses como el Second
signature y First Republic así como la
caída del gigante suizo Credit Suite
según el organismo esto ha aumentado los
riesgos de episodios de corrección
abrupta de los precios de activos y
salidas de capitales especialmente en
economías emergentes como las que
existen en América Latina pero los
banqueros locales diciendo que los
problemas de los bancos internacionales
no tienen ninguna relación con la banca
chilena también señalan que esta
exigencia del gobierno podría crear un
impacto en los créditos y las empresas y
también para las personas pero varios
expertos dicen que medir los efectos
desde ahora todavía es imposible porque
como es la primera vez que se toma una
medida de este tipo Claro Jorge y las
acciones de envidias se dispararon en la
bolsa de Estados Unidos por qué Andrés
subieron un 25% solo hoy Esto debido a
las previsiones de ventas que fueron
superadas muchísimo por las estimaciones
el valor de Mercado de la empresa se
acerca al billón de dólares y en parte
es por la locura que ha causado la
Inteligencia artificial esto porque los
grandes ordenadores que procesan los
datos e impulsan la Inteligencia
artificial generativa como el chat de
pity funcionan con potentes chips
denominados unidades de procesamiento
gráfico nvidia produce alrededor del 80%
de estas unidades según los analistas
chatti pity de openiye por ejemplo se
creó con miles de este tipo de unidades
de lograr el billón de dólares en valor
de Mercado la empresa sería la novena
compañía en alcanzar este hito y
compartiría podio con empresas tan
grandes como meta Apple Microsoft o
tesla viene Jorge vamos a finalizar en
Afganistán uno coma dos millones de
toneladas métricas de trigo están en
riesgo por un brote de langosta marroquí
el brote ocurre en 8 provincias del
Norte y también del noreste de
Afganistán en la zona productiva y de
reserva de trigo más importante de ese
país la langosta marroquíce se alimenta
de más de 150 especies de plantas
incluidos cultivos pastos y 50 cultivos
alimentarios según la organización de
Naciones Unidas para la agricultura y la
alimentación el brote amenaza con
empeorar la situación de inseguridad
alimentaria a finales de este año las
cosechas perdidas oscilarían entre
700.000 y 1,2 millones de toneladas
métricas de trigo hasta una cuarta parte
de la cosecha anual total el daño
económico rondaría los 280 millones de
dólares o los 480 millones de dólares
Jorge Hurtado con la información
económica Muchas gracias seguimos con
[Música]